in 2015 something strange happened to
Britney Spears for the longest time on
her Instagram accounts all you could see
were the usual celebrity sponsored post
and Throwbacks the kind of stuff posted
by a celebrity social media manager not
the celebrity themselves but then
everything suddenly changed Britney's
post became more and more weird and
unhinged out of the blue she started
posting close-up selfies emotional
quotes and memes about the single life
to most of the world it just seemed like
Britney was being eccentric and was just
having fun expressing herself on social
media but her fan to something else
something much darker they saw Britney's
new post as a desperate Cry for Help as
time went on her post got even creepier
like she was trying to give her
followers some kind of riddle to solve
first it was a photo of a Scrabble board
with a caption about how she likes to
make up words for fun then she started
sharing videos of herself dancing
emotionally to her ex-boyfriend Justin
Timberlake's Music Plus a bunch of posts
of roses with strange captions was it a
PR scense just a way to draw attention
to Britney Spears again or was there
something more to this her fans were
getting worried that something bad was
happening to her so they tried
communicating with her directly quote if
you need help Wear Yellow in your next
video one fan wrote in the comments of
her Tik Tok videos and a bunch of people
liked that comment to grab Britney's
attention her response was almost
unbelievable in the very next post
Britney wore a bright yellow top and
even left this caption in the photo My
Florist surprised me today by making the
flower arrangement all different colors
I was so excited I threw on my favorite
yellow shirt and just had to
share the fans had their proof and they
were convinced Britney Spears was in
some kind of trouble and she needed to
be saved but what they actually found
out was worse than they could have ever
imagined because the truth was that
Britney was being held as a legal
prisoner by her own father for more than
a decade for over 10 years Britney's
abusive father had her under basically a
legal slave contract called a
conservatorship so he could work her to
the bone while taking all the money
we've gone over a lot of modern examples
of slavery on this channel but this this
one takes the cake
the story of Britney Spears is perhaps
one of the most disturbing stories out
there when it comes to aess celebrities
so stay dangerous and let's get into
it Britney Spears has gotten a lot of
hate and your business will also get a
lot of hate if you have shipping delays
this holiday season businesses will get
over 10 million negative reviews all
because of shipping delays so if you
have a business where you ship stuff and
you want to avoid having a bunch of
angry customers then you got to check
out ship station ship station helps you
automate most of your manual shipping
work while also hooking you up with the
best shipping rates out there we up to
84% off from Top carers like UPS USPS
and DHL Express that's why over 130,000
companies use ship station including Joe
Ran's honor brand and getting started is
super easy it takes less than 5 minutes
just sign up for the free trial and
create an account then you can connect
your Merchant accounts like Shopify
Amazon Etsy and eBay ship station
supports most marketplaces and stores
and finally you just connect your
shipping carrier account or you can
choose a new carrier and that's it you
can now start getting your products to
your customers faster with less headache
this includes shipping automation
instant tracking updates and a carrier
comparison tool so get ahead of the
Holiday Rush while saving money on
shipping by going to shipstation.com
jran with the link below to get a 60-day
free trial that's shipstation.com jtran
for a free 60-day trial with the link
below thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
to understand why Britney's father would
want to basically imprison her you have
to understand where their parents came
from before Britney spce became a global
Superstar she was just a little girl
with an amazing voice she grew up in
Louisiana with her parents Lynn and
Jamie Spears along with her siblings but
Britney's home life was pretty rough her
dad had a bad drinking problem and her
parents were constantly arguing all this
turmoil caused Britney to turn inward
and she became a really quiet child but
then Britney found her pass passion
singing she started singing with the
church choir and suddenly everyone
realized that she wasn't just good she
had a gift Britney Spears was a singing
Prodigy had no love and S God
know and her parents saw a golden
opportunity Britney was good enough to
be a star so they put all their focus on
making sure the name Britney Spears went
up in lights they invested the little
money they had into Britney success they
got her singing lessons her mom even
moved with her to New York so she could
get more gigs and Britney started
Landing little jobs in commercials and
slowly started building a name for
herself as a child Entertainer and then
in 1992 at the age of 10 she got her
first big break on a show called Star
Search from Kentwood Louisiana here is
10-year-old Britany
[Applause]
Spears when we stand together it's
a we can do anything oh
anything
[Music]
keepie people loved her it was obvious
that this girl was going somewhere and
only a couple of years later she got
cast on a show called Mickey Mouse
Clubhouse at the age of 12 with a couple
of other soon to be famous celebrities
like Christina agilera Ryan Gosling
Carrie Russell and Justin Timber
like
[Music]
C ain't nobody wor
now Ain no smiling
[Music]
faces lying to the
races it wasn't long before Britney sign
with a major record label and by the age
of 16 she was recording her very first
album the infamous Baby One More Time
this was the major turning point of her
career and on the outside it looked like
she became an overnight sensation and
she started selling hundreds of millions
of Records to this day that first album
is still the bestselling album by a
teenage solo artist in the history of
all time Britney had finally become the
star her parents always dreamed about
but it wasn't long before Britney
realized the Dark Side of being a super
famous young naive celebrity
[Music]
once Britney became famous her whole
world changed from the outside it looked
like she had everything fame money
success and on top of that she was
dating the equally famous Justin timlake
the audience already knows who I
am
of course I will get out of the way now
but after a few years of being in the
spotlight things started to go downhill
first Britney and Justin broke up and it
was messy and it all happens as she's
starring as a kind of villain in the
Tabloid accounts of supposed jealous
arguments and then a horrible breakup
with her self-proclaimed First Love
Justin Timberlake we've had a rough year
you've had a year that would test a lot
of people illness in the family mhm a
break up this spasm of publicity about
what happened in from Mexico to
London it was pretty rough she kept
quiet about the breakup but Justin spoke
out almost immediately I promised to her
that I wouldn't say specifically why we
broke up why has he G on his shows he's
talking he's left the impression that
you betrayed the relationship prompting
Justin to write the equally Infamous
song Cry Me a River all of a sudden the
tapids and Paparazzi were not asking her
about her new music anymore all they
wanted to know with the intimate details
of her fresh breakup photographers
became obsessed with harassing her it
was almost like a game of which
Paparazzi could bother her the
most can
I thank you
Britney I just don't like it when you
get in my way of my pictures okay sorry
about that Britney I'm a person just
like you why don't you take one right
now is everything good
Britney you're not listening to me I
want that
studio guys it was a nightmare that no
one in her position would be prepared
for but then in 2004 she met a guy named
Kevin fedeline at the club and it looked
like things were finally starting to
look bright they fell in love and got
married just 3 months after meeting soon
Britney had her first son Shawn and the
following year their second son Jaden it
was everything Britney ever wanted the
money and fame was great but all she
ever really wanted was to settle down
and have a family she thought she was in
the home stretch but Britney's new found
family was something that the paparazzi
just couldn't resist it was a gold mine
for them and they started getting shots
of Britney that were making the public
hate
her
come on guys Britney a bad mom mhm it's
not like did Britney record a bad song
MH is Britney wearing a bad outfit is
Britney in a bad marriage yeah is
Britney a bad mom mhm I mean that's
America for
you yeah but as a mother that has to hit
pretty close to home mhm
Britney started cracking under the
pressure it was basically impossible for
Britney to leave her house without
getting attacked by Paparazzi by 2006
she file for divorce she famously shaved
her head in front of the paparazzi and
then a couple days later she attacked a
photographer's car she was hooked on
drugs around this time could some of
Britney Spear's recent strange Behavior
be due to her being unknowingly drugged
Spear's mother thinks so and now Los
Angeles police are taking a look please
guys don't guys please please guys
Britney just grab the umbrella started
coming after me and starts beating the
passenger side of my
truck hey
you and this all L to this legendary
video when is it professional to
publicly bash someone who's going
through a hard time leave bny
alone please so now there was this brand
new narrative about Britney in the Press
she wasn't just some spoil celebrity
with a bad attitude the media said she
was mentally insane and with Britney at
her most vulnerable the door was wide
open for someone to come in and take
advantage and little did she know that
that someone would come from her own
family
Britney's world was falling apart her
ex-husband insisted that she wasn't
mentally fit enough to take care of
their kids and the court agreed with
them and Britney lost custody to her
children Britney's children were her
entire life so she was devastated not
long after she checked herself into
rehab because it was the only way she
would be allowed to have visitations
with her sons and things went on like
that for a while but then one day in
2018 she had had enough these were her
kids too and she wanted more time with
them so when the time game for her her
to send them back to her dad she locked
herself in a bathroom with one of her
sons instead and this decision changed
everything obviously the only
explanation was that she was crazy
mentally ill so she was admitted to a
hospital for treatment against her will
and by the next day her father Jamie
Spears asked the court for him to be
named Britney's legal conservator but
what exactly does that mean a
conservatorship is a range when someone
needs help taking care of their life and
finances it's usually only used for
people who are on their deathbed or if
they're in a coma or something extreme
like that becoming a conservator means
that you have complete and total control
over a conservatee's life you're legally
allowed to make every single decision
for them as if they were a child so one
would think that Britney's situation
would be too tame to Warrant anything
close to a conservatorship rights wrong
Jam Spears was appointed as the
conservator over Britney's life and her
estate this was at a time when her net
worth was around $40 million this is
according to estimates online which are
usually way off so Britney literally
woke up in the hospital to find out that
her life didn't belong to her anymore
and she was Furious her dad hadn't
really been around and now he wanted to
step in and legally control her life at
her lowest points it was disturbing so
Britney tried to hire her own Loris to
get it overturned but the court say she
legally couldn't hire her own
representation because she was under
conservatorship she basically had no
rights anymore not long after that her
conservatorship went from temporary to
permanent Britney was permanently
trapped and you would think that if
Britney was so far gone that she needed
a conservator to watch over her things
would become a little easier for her
maybe she would finally get the chance
to step out of the spotlight and get her
mental health back in order but no that
was not her father's plan almost
immediately Jamie put his daughter back
to work Britney proceeded to guest start
on How I Met Your Mother there please
don't yell at me because when people
yell at me I have a tendency to start
crying she released a number one album
she even performed a 100 shows around
the world all in the same year that the
court judge her incapable of taking care
of herself and one of the worst parts s
is that she wasn't even entitled to any
of the money she was making Britney was
given a measly $2,000 a week allowance
while her TS alone were bringing in $8
million per week all while her wholesome
Daddy was making double LS and taking
home a percentage of her tourist gross
revenue when all was said and done he
was making around half a million dollar
a year on average while he controlled
Britney while Britney's salary was less
than a quarter of that and in 2011 her
father had a record-breaking year
earning $1.8 million but it wasn't just
her money or her life's work that he was
controlling Britney's dad was monitoring
her
24/7 blackbox security says they
monitored her Communications by
mirroring her iPhone you would be able
to see all
messages all FaceTime calls notes
browser
history um photographs even putting an
audio recording device in her bedroom
when I took a step back and I looked at
everything it really reminded me
of somebody that was in prison every
decision in her life had to be run by
him saying she wants to get married and
have another baby but claims she wasn't
allowed to remove her IUD she also
described being denied things as basic
as coffee her driver's license and her
hair vitamins by the conservatorship and
if she ever tried to fight back against
the conservatorship or if she decided to
stop working they would threaten to take
away her kids and that she would never
be able to see them again Britney had
become nothing more than the Workhorse
it was legal slavery and this
conservatorship was granted by this
gunbag a judge named rev
gerts revers is one hell of a judge
people have said she's extremely
unprofessional a disgusting judge who
lacks any form of Integrity or ethics
she doesn't care about the law all
literally the worst judge I've ever
appeared before she has a score of only
1.7 out of 10 from attorneys who have
reviewed her performance and a 1.0 out
of 10 from non attorneys who have had
their cases appear before her and
interestingly enough celebrity
conservatorships or you know slave
agreements seem to be her specialty she
presented over conservatorship cases for
celebrities like Mickey Rooney an old
actor and producer and Zaza Gabor
another old actress by law a conserva
team must be notified 5 days in advance
so they have the opportunity to get
their own lawyer before someone takes
total control over their life but in
Britney's case her father asked this
judge to wave this rights and the judge
granted it keeping Britney in the dark
once Britney did find out she tried
hiring her own lyer to fight back but
this judge didn't allow her basically
this judge was doing every sketchy thing
imaginable to push this conservatorship
through and then on top of all that this
judge then hosted a paid event with
Britney's co-conservator and the
attorney for her father the event was
called conservative ships for the
high-profile public figure does it work
so just like that the slave contract
went through but the very honorable
Judge rev gitz and Britney's father
apparently weren't the masterminds
behind this conservatorship now that
title goes to a menacing woman named Lou
Taylor Britney Spears's
[Music]
manager
on the surface Lou Taylor is just a
celebrity manager just like any other
celebrity manager but the truth was Lou
Taylor saw celebrities like Britney as a
gold mine to be exploited and exploit
she did before Lou was Britney's manager
she was systematically doing everything
in her power to infiltrate Britney's
life just as all the core drama where
Britney started L teror started stalking
Britney no seriously Britney even
contacted her lawyer saying that Lou was
a crazy stalk so sending random gifts to
her house telling him that she was
terrified of her when that didn't work
Lou started targeting Britney's dad and
bingo that was her in once she got her
in most people believe that it was her
who started convincing Jamie to put
Britney into a conservatorship according
to Britney's mother in her book Lou and
Jamie worked together to plan Britney's
conservatorship for weeks before it
actually went down and as all this drama
was unfolding Lou started making TV
appearances to speak on the Family's
behalf so she could control the
narrative well what's wrong with Dr
Phil's statement is that he made a
statement the family basically extended
an invitation of trust for him to come
in as a resource to support them not to
go out and make public statements and
this wasn't the first time she tried
this she tried to convinced Dina Lohan
to ask for a conservatorship over
Lindsay Lohan's fortune and Courtney
Love alleged that Lou tried to take over
her estate too but Britney Spears was
her jackpot since she took control of
Britney's life her firm has doubled in
value let's look at Stonebridge
investment Council it manages about $52
million of regulatory assets and
business has really boomed since the
founding of the company in 2002 what you
will see is before 2008 which is the
Year Britney Spears conservatorship
started the assets were about half of
what they are now you may be wondering
what Stonebridge investment Council has
to do with Britney Spears and her
conservatorship oh here it is Lis Mary
Taylor has been acting as president
since August 1st 2002 Mitchell only came
on after even though he's listed as the
president now so my working Theory SL
opinion is that Lou Taylor got her
Clause into Britney Spears's estate and
then very quickly funneled it into her
own investment advising firm the only
two people listed as owners and officers
are Louis Taylor and Mitchell Martin Lou
used to be a registered investment
adviser with the SEC but she's no longer
now I'm going to look into the paperwork
just to make sure that Britney's money
did go to Stonebridge wealth management
or investment advisor so I'm not a
conspiracy theorist but I do have a
working and she was doing super sketchy
stuff with Britney's money and brand too
before the Britney Spears Foundation
charity went bankrupt which just $17
left in assets under L watch $50,000 of
those dollars was donated to Mercy
Ministries in Nashville where Lou
happened to be a member on the board Lou
was sued for failing to pay out
commission for a billion dollar perfume
deal she made on Britney's behalf and
she was doing everything she could to
hide the conservatorship Lou even bought
dozens of conservatorship related domain
names to stop people from searching for
answers but despite L's efforts to keep
it all a secret Britney's loyal fans
knew something was off and they were
about to help her break
[Music]
free for years Britney's hardcore fans
knew that something was wrong one guy
named Jordan Miller even ran a website
as far back as 2009 that publicly
advocated against the Britney
conservatorship and after just a few
months he got a call from Jamie Spears
himself telling him that he would
destroy him if he kept it up but even
though some people knew that there was
something disturbing happening it wasn't
until the New York Times released a
groundbreaking documentary about her
story that it finally caught the world's
attention Britney was so focused this is
a girl that's coming from strength
people became fascinated with her sort
of unraveling how we treated her was
disgusting she accepted the conservative
was going to happen but she didn't want
her father to be conservative anytime
there's that amount of money to be made
you have to question the motives of
everyone why is her dad making all of
her decisions why is she still in this
why do we
want and all this attention and uproar
made something incredible happen in
November 2021 after 13 long years under
a brutal conservatorship Britney Spears
was finally
freed free Britney is a reality at
last Friday afternoon in a Los Angeles
courtroom so I just want to thank all of
you I've got a client that I need to
speak
with judge Brenda Penny releasing
39-year-old Britney Spears from the
conservatorship that since 2008 had
controlled every aspect of the pop
star's
existence people were ecstatic Britney
had finally been freed and she actually
thanked all her ashree Britney fans for
helping her Escape I've been in the
conservatorship for 13
years
it's a really long time to be in a
situation you don't want to be in um so
I'm just grateful honestly for each day
and being able to have um the keys to my
car and being able to be independent and
feel like a woman and um owning an ATM
card seeing cash for the first time
being able to buy candles but the
scariest part about Britney's
conservatorship is that she is not alone
because conservatorships are actually an
insanely profitable
business
it's no secret that music label
contracts are known to be predatory well
let's be honest they are not predatory
enough so think of conservatorships as
the ultimate music label contracts where
you don't just own the Masters to a
celebrity songs you own the celebrity
that is why they did this to Britney
Spears and that's why after the industry
saw what they did to Britney Spears they
tried to deal with other celebrities
when Lindsay loohan got caught in a
bunch of public scandals her and
Britney's manager Lou Taylor also tried
to put linday Lohan under a
conservatorship but her dad caught wi of
it and quickly shut it down now whenever
a celebrity steps out of line in the
public eye getting put under a
conservative ship is a legitimate threat
and the great thing about
conservatorships is that if the
conservat starts doing better in life it
shows that the conservatorship is
working but if they do worse it just
proves that they can't take care of
themselves it's a never-ending Loop so
Britney may be freed and finally moving
on to the next next chapter of her life
like suing her dad for everything he's
done to her but we have no idea how many
other celebrities are out there right
now living under lock and key just like
she did for 13 years and it might not be
even under a conservatorship either
there are celebrities out there right
now that are constantly drugged up by
their Circle to keep them docile and
working but we'll sa that for a future
video and if you want to know why
celebrities always seem to end up
depressed on drugs and vulnerable to a
conservatorship like this well then you
got to watch our recent video on why
celebrities are always depressed where
we interviewed arvit Ali who's managed a
celebrities before it's personally one
of my favorite videos we've done
recently and you can watch it right now
by clicking the card on the screen click
the card on the screen to watch
now